many military veterans as you know they
come home from their service they carry
internal wounds that can damage them
forever Dean Reynolds shows us how
songwriters are helping some of them
recover with the power of music from
this building in Nashville and the
recording studio inside come the sounds
of healing sure struck and learn it's
the music of redemption words of renewal
from America's traumatized soldiers
[Music]
it's called Operation song a joint
effort with the Veterans Administration
to turn trauma into treatment and give a
voice to those who've suffered in
silence placing them with real
songwriters to make their stories heard
we joined them before the pandemic hits
[Music]
you want to talk about the things you
buried no Brian zombie Ozzy was a Marine
from 1987 to 1993 after discharge he
fell into a deep suicidal depression
there's been a lot of little things a
longtime cone and for over a decade was
living a nameless existence aggravated
by post-traumatic stress disorder I was
labeled many different things it's
highly medicated you know many pills
every day and that medication worked and
maybe numb I really don't know where to
start
um well start the beginning I'm here to
write your song I'm here to write your
story you have to make it honest and
real operation song paired zombie I see
with singer/songwriter Jason Seaver
couple suicide attempts know that really
yeah paddles is pre-ban gosh man that's
why I had a brain injury Wow did it to
myself in just four hours a song emerged
and a catharsis
you know that the immediate result of
what music does and how powerful it is
is something really really cool to
witness so far the stories of more than
800 men and women have been told this
way and it's the music that's designed
to give these veterans of feeling of
resilience of overcoming
[Music]
no what does it's impossible to know if
this will have a lasting impact but for
one weekend at least the darkness parted
and the light broke through now no job
John knows me and that makes two
[Music]
Dean Reynolds CBS News Nashville I just
think the smile on his face is worth it
operation song continues to help
veterans during this pandemic by holding
writing sessions over zoom it also
hosted a virtual retreat with veterans
and musicians back in March Anthony it's
so interesting how sometimes you can't
say the words out loud but you can set
it you can put them in a song and then
you can sing them so they're still put
out in the universe it's very powerful
yeah it's very emotional I think I think
it gives those servicemen and women a
chance to take these feelings they've
had and put them someplace to sort of
hold them and it frees them in a certain
way I think Gail it's very very powerful
stuff